eggs are great they are so versatile and
once you've mastered how to cook them
trust me the door then opens to a wide
range of delicious options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mess
let's start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice the bacon bacon in
no salt
a little touch of pepper start off in a
high heat get our bacon really nice and
crispy otherwise you just boil the bacon
and it's got that soft unpleasant
texture in the potato
go down the gas and now start adding
your veg breakfast Chopper red pepper
and add it to the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now soak them off
and the peppers have been cooked now
from that sort of rendered fat in the
bacon
and then
spring onions just Bunch them up
slice them I want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now for the eggs
cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs I'm gonna fill it
right to the very top
and more importantly when I turn this
out
I want it like a gateau nice and thick
so slice through and seal those
wonderful veg
I'm gonna season the eggs
with some Parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it has a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chop
basil I want to chop that sort of
roughly
because I want to see those flecks of
green going in
weren't looking charming and how many
times have you seen a dull omelette
frittatas in my mind really help
encapsulate the magic of having
Savory eggs
cooked beautifully but with texture now
just before we add the eggs I've got
this
peaceful Little Ghost cheese and it's
strong and powerful so I want to slice
it
into little chunks
and then just
have it dotted around I want to discover
these little pockets of creamy goat's
cheese now slowly
have the eggs
fill that right up
and he's spoon now just let all that egg
go down to the bottom
bring it back up the boil
and sort of clean around the sides and
then some of this delicious salty
creamy ghost cheese over the top
yeah I want it melting like a
perfect slice
cheese on toast
nice now from there turn the grill on
for four to five minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
now
just looking at that
delicious take a little paring knife and
just make sure
it's released
from the sides just take your panel
tab
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan now
board over the pan turn that gently
and just
Shake say a little prayer and lift off
beautiful now
from there
there is there look
now
slice
through
hmm
see how soft and creamy that is in the
center
and that goat cheese is just melting
almost like a little sauce inside so
exciting but more importantly so easy to
do it's got texture it's got creaminess
and that for me will beat any omelette
for brunch so with a stack of hot
buttered toast and a steaming pot of
coffee this easy potato turned the
humble egg into the perfect dish for
kicking off the weekend
foreign
versatile protein packed and delicious
here are three more of my favorite
recipes give your brunches a tasty twist
first up North African eggs
[Music]
and olive oil to a hot pan
the fried finely chopped onions and red
and green peppers
then chopped garlic and chili
and cook until sausage
until it's worth bringing you with eggs
giving the dish a lovely hot kick
next add fresh chopped tomatoes then
cumin seeds and Fry until the seeds are
fragrant and the tomatoes are lovely and
soft season
next make welding a spicy sauce and
crack in your eggs
[Music]
then cover them cook on a low heat for
five minutes so the whites are set and
the yolks are still lovely and runny to
finish slice bring onions and coriander
and simply sprinkle over
fresh and spicy and deliciously
different in North African eggs ready in
under 20 minutes has this worth getting
up late for
[Music]
next x-made Super indulgent in brunch
cheat souffle with three cheeses
[Music]
sugar
skin powder
[Music]
make the one in the center
let's simply beat six eggs together
point the well the Whisk into the flour
then whiskey milk making the mixture
lovely and light next add the three
cheeses cottage cheese grated monterey
jack or cheddar
[Music]
cheese
for extra richness knobs of butter
butter a baking dish
pour in your Rich cheesy chicks to Flame
mix
in a medium oven and bake for 40 minutes
[Music]
a stunning fuss-free souffle that's
ideal for brunch
squeezy egg dish is a salty and
succulent prawn and feta omelets
[Music]
pour olive oil into a hot pan add
chopped tomatoes
spring onions and Fry
season
next add cooked prawns and a Sprinkle of
chili flakes to give it a lovely kick of
heat cook through and set aside next
take four eggs
add olive oil to your frying pan and
pour in the eggs
sprinkle on freshly chopped oregano
which works brilliantly with eggs
then spoon over the spicy prawns crumble
over creamy feta cheese and grill for a
couple of minutes
this is eggs to the end of degree backed
with different tastes textures and
flavors all working wonderfully together
perfect
one super versatile ingredient three
mouth-wateringly different recipes
brunch has never been better nice
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
first up red pepper as you've seen great
for frittata and North African eggs but
you need to know how to cut them
properly
I absolutely love these Peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor with a really nice crunchy
texture and the most exciting thing
about the peppers is that they're just
as delicious raw or cooked to identify
the perfect pepper must be smooth and
firm and not a wrinkle in sight now how
to cut the perfect pepper
stalk off
pepper down and get the knife start from
the top and slice all the way around
basically we're going to be slicing
around the seeds look no faffing around
like this little perfect Christmas tree
of seeds and you haven't got the mess
all over your board and more importantly
it's twice as quick discard that now
we're going to cut it into a julienne
flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board because
it's a lot easier to slice through the
pepper and just lift the knife
up and down
and basically julienne is a chef word
for strips
these are absolutely perfect for a
sauteing and that's what we're looking
for there crunchy delicious and more
importantly
No Seeds beautiful
great brunch recipes start with a
delicious fresh egg my tried and tested
wages tell if your egg is fresh is to
Simply place it into a bowl of cold
water and fresh egg will sink and a
stale one will float
shell goes into
their eggs my tip for removing it is
simply use a larger piece
Magic
[Music]
fries winning fried eggs fry them in oil
adding a tablespoon of water and color
the water steams the top of the egg to
Perfection
bagels are brilliant for brunch my tip
to make sure you always have them on
hand is to stock up your freezer
but make sure you slice them first that
way you can pop them straight into your
toaster
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course a
hundred recipes to stay your life on
we're about to show you my recipe for
delicious spicy pancakes tuck it
underneath there pull it back and Roll
But first here's my guide to buying
beautiful eggs knowledge is crucial the
more you know about where your
ingredients are from and how they
produce the better
in my home kitchen I use eggs in
abundance they are so versatile they get
into grips with them or make
sing it's good girlies tricky chickens a
decade of experience under her belt
Helen from Harris Farm in Hertfordshire
is a real Egghead and has some valuable
tips to share
the hens we keep are designed to lay
probably
300 350 eggs a year
free range means that the bird must have
access to the outside at all times
chickens love grass they Peck at
whatever's on the ground and it makes
the eggs a lovely Rich golden color and
the flavor is tremendous
tell if an egg is really fresh crack it
open put it on a dish and you will see
that it sits up really quite High and
the white is really nice and tight
around the side of the yolk the bus
range of eggs out there to experiment
with
what you know try lining up your
brunches with something different this
is a band to make they are Miniature
chickens the yolks are quite large
compared to the whites of the egg and
they're absolutely delicious making
scrambled eggs off of them because
they're much more creamier all together
than say a chicken's egg this is the
duck's egg these ones are sort of an
off-white color but they can be sort of
creamy greeny colors compared to chicken
eggs the duck's yolk is richer and
creamier and the white is fluffier when
whisked which is why they're so
incredible for bacon this is the goose
egg this is quite a large egg probably
equivalent to three chicken eggs the
geese literally lay for about 12 weeks
from my few geese we've had about
128 they're amazing layers but just for
the very short season the amazing thing
is the color of the yolks of these they
are usually quite orange the geese don't
actually eat anything other than grass
they are just grazers and that makes a
huge difference to the color of the yolk
s
Tiny But incredibly tasty they only take
a minute to soft boil I love delicious
dipped in celery salt if you've got a
big appetite or you're making a brunch
for a big group of friends you could try
the giant rare egg from South America
the equivalent of 10 headaches they're
great scrambled or as a massive omelette
another interesting option is the
pheasant egg small but rich in flavor
they're perfect for homemade Scotch eggs
or hard-boiled in a salad you can keep
eggs in your fridge but ideally when you
go to use them take them out bring them
up to room temperature because you'll
find that they will cook better just
make sure that there's no cracks in them
and then you'll be assured that they're
nice healthy tasting eggs
[Music]
foreign
should be a laid-back Affair and a treat
so the dishes need to be easy to cook
but never boring
my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level of flavor and
excitement
fiery and irresistible spicy pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are a really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically nonstick pan
just a touch of seasoning the salt helps
to dry out the cumin even more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up
and then just slice nice little thin
slices in there
and then keep that punched up
shake the chili
[Music]
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now
garlic
nice now add olive oil to your toasted
cumin seeds and then with the garlic
ginger and chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but the time I
spent in India everybody was eating
something Savory for breakfast it was
extraordinary
to your bowl
and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
[Music]
pepperonium
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and I've got a color an instant
change leftover potatoes just slice them
smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan all
the potatoes stained I want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge
season those potatoes and it really
helps to bring out
spice beautifully
[Music]
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic chili Ginger
and cumin seeds Touch of salt and pepper
nothing worse than the Bland pancake
one whole egg
milk all the jugged one hand and whisk
whatever the secrets to get that really
nice smooth paste but whisking that egg
first and brings it together and then
you're milking
[Music]
don't put all the milk in because then
you're going to get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it not going Lumpy
look at that
milky
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix well just
a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring a nice crispy
Edge to the mixture now just taste
thank you that's the texture pan on
the larger the pan the better it helps
to create the nice thin even surface I
want that mix going all the way around
the pan before you put the mixture into
the pan make sure you give your pancake
mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot
turn down the gas
Touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix in
one and a half ladles
and then roll it around it's just really
nice and thin I want to see the ginger
the garlic that's what I'm looking for
in there now back onto the heat it only
starts to remove from the bottom of the
pan and lifts itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off the pan a
little shake that releases it and then
just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the content
of tossing then use a spatula and turn
it over now that's exactly what I want
that nice sort of crisp edge around the
side the color on the pancake is so
important
now roll it rounds
just let it slide out
beautifully
now
the exciting part filling them
your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll there
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there pull it back and roll
[Music]
treat just mix chopped coriander with
natural yogurt
it's really nice cooling agent sit out
on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious spicy pancakes amazing
right now is all that cooking with chili
for me chilies are an incredible
ingredient in The Cook's Arsenal the
capable of transforming dishes added
excitement heat and a wonderful taste
I'm going to show you how to get the
grips with the intense flavor first up
red mullet with sweet chili sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off peace
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half
and those seeds inside are very powerful
incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic two cloves of
garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin so it
helps the puree
chilies in the pasta water garlic in
such a salt and it will touch of sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
salt and the sugar
really helps the puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
Touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions I want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
and fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with a red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
[Music]
well it's delicious look at that
beautiful
the longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's gonna coat the top of
the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
and it helps to really grind the peanuts
down some beautiful dried chili flakes
creates a nice sort of warm heat I'm
using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander
makes the coriander in to the peanuts
and look I like them quite textured I
don't want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly to coat the fish with the chili
and peanut seasoning in a separate Bowl
beat two eggs along with a splash of
fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down
cover that red bullet
oh beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice and
piping hot if we put the fish in and the
Pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chili
just going to slide off the fish so we
need to sear it in and get it nice and
crisp in and lay away from you
beautiful
[Music]
but the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your olive oil
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
turn
nice and gently
you want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed crispness
which adds A really lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with a really
nice piping hot olive oil you've got
that really nice roasted Crunch and it
goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now and take them out
[Music]
in the sauce touch on the bottom and the
tail of each fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut encrusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies
this dish uses the exciting Taste of a
chili found deliciously elegant and
subtle flavor
as you become more confident using
chilies you'll find they can transform
your cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes and
cherries and chilies
[Music]
spicy sauce sliced anchovies garlic
next dried cheese
[Music]
then add the anchovy all to a hot pan
and Fry the chopped ingredients
[Music]
add half cherry tomatoes
chopped black olives and salted Capers
cook to combine those flavors
[Music]
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great stall covered Staples
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain hamster sauce one splash of the
water it's full of starch which is a
great silky consistency
then season with pepper and chocolate
pack your Big Bowl flavors and ready in
under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes and
Cherry and cherries
my next deliciously different chili
recipe
is grilled corn with Chipotle chili
butter
[Music]
coriander
then add softened butter
soaked Chipotle chilies in hot water
these are dried jalapenos with an
amazing Smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
s mixed together and seasoned
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
to eat smother the cob in the butter and
crumble over Lancashire cheese
oh fantastically messy to eat grilled
corn with Chipotle chili butter and
utterly delicious Smoky treat
[Music]
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense
then chopped garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice and brown clothes cinnamon
nutmeg
and allspice
and a seasoned with salt and pepper and
combine with olive oil
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly
[Applause]
available to a hot dish
ground the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
[Music]
then add Worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
half spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
thank you three different chilies three
amazing flavors three irresistible
dishes
nice
next five more of my 100 tips that'll
make your life easier in the kitchen
first up how to deseed chili to get the
seeds out hold it upright and just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot we're just releasing
them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
Smarties
and there
got the little button bit off
[Music]
amazing
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand
chillies are surprisingly versatile if
you love them and save your dishes and
my tip is to try adding them to melted
chocolate ganache for chocolate chili
truffles or sprinkled over fresh fruit
like mango or watermelon
to prevent burning sensitive skin and
working with chillies to get rid of that
spice and that heat on your fingers a
little bit of lemon squeeze a little bit
of lemon juice and that instantly gets
rid of the heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a Mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails give your drink a very
different sort of a king this is my
ultimate cookery course 100 recipes to
stay your life on I'll be showing you an
amazing spicy beef salad take a little
teaspoon of your dressing and just go
over the beef look first the secret to
cooking fantastic Foods is to start with
great ingredients the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so don't be scared ask lots of questions
and learn and when it comes to chilies
there's no one better to ask than chili
grower Joanna Plum who's been farming
chillies from mild to mind blown for
over 11 years I eat chilies all the time
every single day she grows over 60 Types
on her farm and really knows her
poblanos from a habaneros
people think that chilies are all about
heat
actually it's about Flavor as well some
are sweet some are aromatic and they can
be used in so many different dishes when
you go shopping and you're looking for a
chili what should you be looking for
what you want to do is look at the chili
and it needs to be nice and firm and
glossy generally the bigger the chili
the milder it's going to be the smaller
the chili the hotter and if it's small
and wrinkly like this one it's going to
blow your socks off another way to tell
if a chili is hot or not is to split it
open and smell it if it's a super hot
chili it'll clear your sinuses the heat
of a chili comes from an oil called
capsaicin and that is concentrated
mainly at the top of the chili where the
seeds are now when you're cooking with a
chili and you want the flavor of the
chili but not too much of the heat start
by just using the bottom of it as you
get closer to the seeds that chili is
going to get hotter so if you remove the
seeds that also does remove some of the
heat there's thousands of varieties out
there because they cross pollinate very
very easily and that's why the world's
hottest chili is always changing
Joanna's rice with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
Aromas and of course levels of heat is
important to buy what you like here are
my top chillies whatever your desired
kick at the mild end these are great for
stuffing have a delicate flavor and
often use in Mexican dishes starting to
get hot the jalapeno when they're green
they're like spicy bell pepper the
redder they are the sweeter they are
start to pack a punch long thin and
pungent they're great Thai Dishes and
are often green or red and at the top
end down as well these Lantern shaped
demons have a delicious fruity taste and
there's a firecracker of the chili World
another way to use chilies is to smoke
them and to make chipotle what it is
it's just a Mesquite smoked red jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can almost get
that like Smoky bacon sort of flavor out
of it so you would use this and anything
that you would slow cook so you're
eating a chili and it's really too hot
for you the best way to get rid of that
heat is to drink some milk or a dairy
product like yogurt whatever you do
don't go for water or for beer don't be
trying to find new types of chilies that
you're cooking experimenting with these
amazing fiery beasts is a great excuse
for getting hot-headed in the kitchen
they give you a natural high much like
when you've been exercising so your
endorphins are released and you just
feel good chilies make you happy and
they're also an aphrodisiac
[Music]
they're putting the balance in the hot
spices of chili with sweet sour and
salty flavors
if you want a new Twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili my next
recipe is super simple to make but have
wonderful depth and complexity of
flavors spicy beef salad chilies if you
use them confidently they can really add
a new dimension to the style of cooking
but the real trick is finding that
balance of flavors that really suits you
because that's the most important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly season the steaks generously
Salt and Pepper Push that seasoning in
to the sirloin take the sirloin out of
the fridge literally 20 minutes before
you want to cook them so it gets up to
room temperature they cook more evenly
but more importantly you can actually
season
right inside the steak this little bit
of fat down here season that as well
because that is what we want to roast
and get that really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away again into the pan and lay
away if you don't hear that noise the
minute those steaks hit the pan don't
put them in so the secret now is getting
that color on the steak turning it once
and once only and cooking it for two and
a half minutes each side what I want to
do is to get that bit of fat rendered so
it adds a lot more flavor just hold the
steak down like that and that starts to
melt the fat which makes it so much more
tender there should be no white fat left
anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so he spend less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in it says rare I'm happy for
them to be rare Because by the time I
let them rest
we're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them rest
one
two let's get my juices over
[Music]
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out on a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out
cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chili Works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just
slam it down pops out very very quickly
in little touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it pureing
clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chili and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce fresh lime this is a simple
fresh chili dressing and it was
something I fell in love with in Vietnam
and Cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar quick taste
wow right vegetables a great bus free
way to get super thin ribbons of carrot
to use a veg peeler when they're that
thin they take the vinaigrette so much
better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
[Music]
lovely give another dimension of the
salad and these are banana shallot they
are incredibly mellow
very sweet across
chop up
the shalom
and mix that through I want some
Sweetness in there now little Vine
Tomatoes slice them
in half smart as in shallot radish
carrots and tomatoes next peel and
sliced cucumber chopped spring onions
and Shred baby gem lettuce and then
finally get some fresh mint it's young
mint so you don't need to take all those
stalks off all you do is hold a bunch
upside down and then take it for a
little trim
and just chop that once through
look at that nice minted salad a couple
of tablespoons of dressing don't flood
the salad with the dressing you can
always add but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chili and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around that salad beautiful
[Music]
onto the plate the steaks rested it's
now nice and medium rare a little bit of
fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose it's kept that steak nice
and moist
slice going with the grain it's almost
like slicing through butter and look
inside
beautiful pink
you slice the beef too thinly then it
goes Stone Cold and more importantly all
the goodness runs out of it nice thick
slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
stick that on top and finish it off with
some toasted peanuts peanuts in
now there's nuts are really toasted nuts
on
get another pan and just
Crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
you can hear our crunch they are another
texture another taste of the salad
and then from there sprinkle
finally take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty very well textured spicy beef
salad
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cut